[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frad bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline dans la presse d'abord
les réactions Hélène au texte final de
la cop27 qui s'est achetée hier à charmé
le char en Égypte et le moins que l'on
puisse dire Pauline c'est que le bilan
de ce 27e sommet de l'ONU sur le climat
provoque des réactions mitigées les
échos le quotidien a économique français
évoque à la fois on le voit les avancées
et les impasses de cet accord avancer
pour ce qui est de la création d'un fond
d'indemnisation pour les pays les plus
touchés par le changement climatique
comme par exemple le Pakistan qui a été
touché en septembre par des inondations
catastrophiques mais impasse également
pour ce qui est des émissions de CO2 et
le poids des énergies fossiles l'urgence
attendra libération dénonce pour sa part
un accord à minima en décalage en tout
cas avec la gravité de la situation il
fut un temps où l'on se serait félicité
du verre à moitié plein mais l'urgence
climatique impose de ne plus se
satisfaire de encore en demi teinte
arrachées après 36 heures de
prolongation regrette le journal et ce
sentiment largement partagé de fin non
shot Times estime lui aussi que les
discussions ont échouées sur ce qui
était ce qui est en réalité le point le
plus crucial c'est à dire les émissions
de CO2 et que le financement des pertes
dédommages est certes positifs mais que
la priorité aurait été de stopper la
cause du préjudice
quotidien britanniques l'objectif de
limiter le réchauffement climatique à 1
degré et demi qui avait été fixé par
l'accord de Paris est mort et enterré
mais le journal refuse malgré tout de
perdre espoir chaque fraction de degré
supplémentaire augmente la souffrance
humaine mais c'est précisément pour
cette raison que la lutte pour mettre
fin à l'industrie des combustibles
fossiles doit s'intensifier près de le
journal le bilan de cette cop27 en
dessin c'est avoir avec celui-ci de
Menton Morlan pour The Times qui réunit
sur ces négociateurs qui disent très à
rédiger un accord à condition de laisser
tomber les réductions d'émissions de CO2
à be mousse pectomin préparé la fumée
blanche sans elle-même l'un d'entre eux
comme au Vatican quand les cardinaux
lecteurs se mettent d'accord sur le
nouveau pape dans le dessin de coco pour
Libération cette référence je décèdes
différences avant la COP 27 après la
cop27 les différences ne cherchez pas il
n'y en a pas et c'est toujours le même
homme qui se noie fin de la COP 27
Hélène écoute en voix du Mondial de foot
au Qatar le monde entier est au cathare
jubile le quotidien katari
le journal célèbre je cite l'avènement
d'un rêve catarié arabe longtemps
attendu et finalement exaucé avec ce
Mondial 2022 qui pourraient la grande
capacité de l'émirats à réunir tout le
monde sur son sol d'après le monde la
cérémonie d'ouverture a permis aux
monarque du Qatar Tamines altany de
mettre en scène leur taux en force du
Moyen-Orient de son pays au Moyen-Orient
avec la présence dans la tribune
d'honneur hier de leader qui rêvait il y
a encore moins de 2 ans de mettre le
Qatar à genoux le prince héritier
saoudien Mohamed Ben Salman dit MBS et
le président égyptien abdelfata elsissi
malgré la Concorde affichée et les
dimensions olympiques des cérémonies
d'ouverture le lancement de ce cata de
ce mondial s'est terminé sur une fausse
note pour le
Qatar éliminé on le sait
par l'équateur c'est le premier pays
organisateur à voir était avoir perdu un
match d'ouverture de zéro face à
l'équateur ce qui lui vaut
commentaires pas très amène du Times le
quotidien britannique le Qatar a
peut-être investi 200 milliards de
dollars dans ce mondial mais cet argent
clinquant ne lui a pas permis de
s'acheter ne serait-ce que la moitié
d'une équipe digne de ce nom enfin de
cités voilà battu mais pas éliminer le
Qatar en tout cas pas pour l'instant et
laine les Bleus eux ont rendez-vous
demain face à l'Australie mais devront
faire sans carême Benzema qui est
forfait pour la compétition et l'absence
du joueur blessé à l'entraînement laisse
mal augurer de ce Mondial pour les Bleus
d'après le gratuit 20 Minutes qui
exprime ses doutes sur leur chance
d'avancer très loin dans cette
compétition en l'absence de Benzema une
large partie du destin de l'équipe de
France repose désormais sur les épaules
de l'attaquant parisien Kylian Mbappé
dixit l'équipe qu'il voit déjà marcher
dans les pas de Pelé le champion le
champion brésilien le seul joueur à
avoir remporté deux Coupes du monde
avant l'âge de 24 ans qui aime baper lui
fêtera ses mettre en le 10 décembre
prochain deux jours après la finale de
cette coupe du monde voilà ce qui
s'appelle avoir la pression aux
États-Unis Joe Biden hélène a lui fêter
ses 80 ans un âge qui fait débat alors
que le président américain envisage de
se représenter en 2024 d'après Wall
Street Journal certains membres du parti
démocrate estime qu'il est temps pour
Joe Biden qui se présente comme un pont
entre l'ancienne et la nouvelle
génération de son parti et qu'il est
temps pour lui de prendre sa retraite
oui Joe Biden a fait un travail
formidable en étant le pont qu'il avait
promis d'être mais il est temps de
laisser la place à une nouvelle
génération à notamment déclaré un de ses
camarades démocrates politico lui presse
au contraire Joe Biden de se représenter
le site critique d'ailleurs la guerre
générationnelle actuellement en cours
selon lui au sein du parti démocrate il
cite la féministe avant-gardiste Betty
freeden qui dénonçait je la cite une
mystique de l'âge plus redoutable encore
que la mystique féminine à propos
d'anniversaire Hélène juste une
précision Kylian Mbappe est née le 20
décembre et non le 10 je le sais car
c'est le même jour que moi quelques
années près voilà pour la précision de
ce quitte pas là-dessus Hélène non la
vieillesse n'est pas un naufrage et la
jeunesse non plus d'ailleurs Pauline de
gardiennes rapporte que la première
ministre de Nouvelle-Zélande a harderne
a annoncé vouloir faire adopter une loi
pour porter l'âge de vote à 16 ans
d'après le journal cette annonce fait
suite à une décision historiques de la
Cour suprême qui estime que l'âge de
votre actuel de 18 ans est
discriminatoire et qu'il viole les
droits humains les plus jeunes merci
beaucoup Hélène à tout à l'heure